hey youtubers it's Charlie and the Walking
Dead is back. it literally picked up
moments after the mid-season finale.
it was a huge tonal shift from that
high-octane attack. you can think of that
episode as more like a walker buffet. And
this episode as like the dessert.
A 110 ounce jar putting dessert. Quick
announcement though I'm doing a weekly
giveaway in all my reviews videos.
It's gonna be a 20 dollar Amazon
gift card. All you have to do is be a
SUBSCRIBER and leave a comment.
I'll just be picking a random winner and I'll
announce that in my Q&A video
that I'll post tomorrow.
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but I'm going to start with
my Top 5 moments and then I'll  do my review.
So everybody grab a spoon and get some
others pudding! Number 5
Michonne eulogizes Hershel. In my
mind she just went back to the prison to
see what had happened since that
midseason finale
and happened upon Hershel. She wasn't
ONLY looking for him.
In a way though she did give him the
final peace that he deserved. who was
really touching given what The Governor
did.
Speaking of which, we actually finally saw
that gunshot wound.
Greg Nicotero actually ended up bringing
that Animatronic Hershel head to
Talking Dead.
Remember that time on Talking Dead when
Chris Hardwick tried to feed pudding to
that dead Hershel head?
SO WRONG. Number 4 - Carl almost has to
kill Rick.
Next to Carl getting buried beneath a
pile walkers this was one of the most
intense moments in the episode.
Which is why I chose it over to the
other close calls that Carl had.
Watching Carl just break at the thought of having to kill his dad
was so horrifying. Rick had actually been
making those Weezy Walker sounds the
entire episode.
He was so beat up he looked and moved
like a walker too.
This fake out moment was just the
payoff to that. I kept thinking there were
walkers just around the corner where
ever they went. But it was always just
Rick making those sounds. Number 3 -
Michonne's flashback dream sequence.
This was the most beautifully shot scene
in the episode. Michonne had really
reverted her season 3 personality.
You know the coping mechanism of just
shutting everything down and taking pets.
The dream sequence was just her way of
processing what had happened.
And I don't know what would have
happened had she not known about Carl
and Rick's footprints.
If you can catch the reference, those
two water pets that Michonne had at the
beginning of the episode were just
visual metaphors for Mike and Terry.
You know the men she lost. Number 2 - Carl
finally has it out with a comatose Rick.
I think having Rick passed out the whole
time sped Carl up to that breaking point
where he could just verbalize
all the things he was angry about. Yes, he
did say some very awful things.
But he wasn't actually mad at Rick. At
least not in the way he made it sound.
He's just expressing all the rage and
frustration that's built up over the
past 3 seasons.
All the friends and family they lost, you
know their entire way of life being
destroyed.
This has really been my favorite scene
with the two of them together. They've had a
couple moments together this season, but
none that were this intense.
Just let it out Carl, just let it out.
It's okay to cry. And my Number 1 moment -
Carl gets his victory pudding!
This was Carl's big moment of triumph,
you know, a big reaffirmation.
He said "I Win" twice during the episode
and this was the second time.
Everyone had lost so much that the chalk
on the door and that pudding on the roof
was just a way for him to take
something back, to get at least one big
win.
I mean seriously, Michonne had this
amazing trip, you know, back to reality.
But his was really Carl's episode. What is
his future though?
Is he going to end up turning into
someone like Michonne? She did just knock
on the door at the end of the episode
and Rick said, you know, "It's for you". So
clearly he's going to be spending a lot
of time with her.
It was such an amazing episode though,
let me know what your
favorite moment was!
As a midseason premiere I have to give
this a solid "A".
You know, largely due to Chandler Riggs
being so awesome in it. And the deep dive
into Michonne, which we haven't gotten
in a long time.
The story was a direct adaptation of
issues 49 and 50 the comic book too.
The stories are always informed by the comic, but this was actually a literal
beat for beat adaptation.
Hershel's funeral was a great payoff for
the fandom. I had so many questions on my
Walking Dead videos since
episode 8, about how Herschel would
totally be a walker. It's a sentence
that's worse than death, so it was really
nice to see him laid to rest.
Speaking of which, it was really nice to
finally get an answer on The Governor.
A lot of people bet me that he would
totally show up as a walker, but when we
saw the gunshot wound in his head,
we totally got our answer. I was a little
disappointed that we did not get to see
baby Judith.
Robert Kirkman actually said we would
get a definitive answer about her
very soon.
Nicotero actually did imply that we
would see The Governor again before the
season finale.
But obviously knowing what we know now,
he'll probably just be a hallucination.
I can't say enough about the stylistic
choices in the episode though, when
Michonne was mowing down her
heard of Walker's, the camera panned out,
you know, to reveal this neat
little circle
It looked just like the dead Night's
Watchmen circle that the White Walkers
left for Jon Snow during Season 3 of Game
of Thrones.
Great story, great style. It's really
gonna be hard to top this next week.
the good news is that we will pick up
with the group we didn't see in this
episode so I'm crossing my fingers we
will see baby Judith.
Remember, I'm posing my Q&A video
for this tomorrow. So ask me any question
you want about this episode or the rest
of the season.
I'll also be announcing the random giveaway
winner in that too. After this episode I
am so pumped about the rest of the
season though.
Right now click here for my TOP 10
Predictions and click here for that
Q&A Video. I'll add the annotation as soon
as I post it.
Thank You so much for watching, I'll see you guys Tonight. High Fives!